or at the Searles Valley earthquake that
occurred about 17 kilometers from the
city of rich crest California in this
sequence so far there's been about 1400
aftershocks 17 magnitude for aftershocks
including 15.4 and so sorry so this
event occurred within the Little Lake
fault zone it looks like to the best
that we can tell so far that there are
at least two faults that are involved
with this earthquake and there's about a
6 percent chance that there'll be
magnitude 6 or larger earthquake in the
coming days but that will go down with
time that is past
I can add a bit to that and then we can
take questions
speak to the mic so preliminary
indications as far as we've seen so far
the shaking the ground motions from this
earthquake seem to be pretty typical for
a magnitude 6.4 earthquake in California
the damage was relatively light in
Ridgecrest one point here is that the
town of Ridgecrest is quite young it
only started in the 1940s so that's
after California had seismic provisions
in the statewide Building Code so there
there aren't older and vulnerable
buildings there like there are in some
other places there there is a team in
the field at this point doing
reconnaissance looking at the surface
rupture so this earthquake was large
enough to break to the surface part of
the break was outside the Navy base most
of the sequence in the break is within
the China Lake Navy base where access is
restricted the part of it that's outside
has been investigated and there's a team
that's been on the base with with the
cooperation of the base they've done a
helicopter flyover and reported that
there is a significant surface rupture
that aligns with the faults that you see
from the from the aftershock so we'll be
getting more information as they land
and were able to get the pictures in the
earthquake early warning system which
you may have heard about did function as
designed there was an initial alert that
went out after 6.9 seconds it went to a
group of beta testers and so that was
that was received and with that we can
take questions
there is an LA County app that is
different and that's more publicly
available so the kid named Jake alert
system developed by the USGS is still
under development and it is it is being
delivered to a set of beta users that
the system is not has not been ruled out
gold out yet because it's still under
development that's a great question so
as I mentioned before there's about 17
magnitude fours which might be a little
bit higher than an average but not
necessarily not seen before but we're
going to continue to monitor this over
time and see how things unfold and you
said there was a 5.4 when was that and
with the vet look like that was this
morning at 407 407 407 a.m. did that do
any not that I'm aware but you have to
check with emergency services you know
these surface ruptures doctor hub went
to those how would you characterize that
what does that look like
it literally looks like a scar across
the desert floor so in a crack
sometimes it an earthquake like this
moves the ground laterally so one side
goes sideways relative to the other in
the desert it's hard to see because
you're just offsetting sand and and
tumbleweeds but you can see the cracks
that have a little bit of opening to
them so we'll be seeing pictures of that
very very soon and some of them are on
social media already
yeah so overwhelmingly the break is
within the base there are some base
facilities they've apparently sustained
some damage on the base but it's it's
not and then there's a little bit of
breaking that that extends to highway
178 which is trona Road
but not in not in an urban area
yeah an event of this size is going to
keep producing aftershocks for years so
but the rates are going to decay with
time just about every day that goes on
it's going to get cut probably
significantly more
and you mentioned the early warning
system and the beta testers how you said
it worked as designed how much of it a
warning did they get and was people in
Los Angeles as well as beta testers
outside of LA they don't have all of
those numbers off the top of my head so
the first alert went out after 6.9
seconds and in the details I don't know
but again it went to a group of beta
testers there's a lot of tricky issues
to be worked out before the system is
fully rolled out as we've seen there you
know the communication and some of the
decisions are are difficult I believe
that's still under discussion and we
there there's a trade-off if you're
sending off alerts out of when light
shaking is expected there's the there's
a concern that people might start to
kind of dismiss the alerts and not pay
as much attention if stronger shaking is
predicted so the value of the system is
really getting out an alert if people
are going to experience damaging shaking
what's the threshold the threshold now
I'm looking at the person who knows the
answer intensity five
in tents oh okay yeah I'm sorry I don't
have all the numbers off the top of my
head but intensity for which is a level
of shaking that will rattle your windows
for example and then intensity five as a
level that might knock things off of
deaths it really depends it could either
be a magnitude for earthquake nearby or
a magnitude six-and-a-half at 50
kilometers
it's mostly in that up in that region I
believe the 5.4 was felt to some extent
into this area but for the most part
they're going to be Fiat felt enriched
crashed Ronin that the desert
communities this general area is the
little like fault zone and so there's
there's many different faults that are
within this region that's what we think
exactly a fault zone is just a region
that has lots of faults all within yeah
I mean I I think that this the l-shape
is particularly interesting and that's
something that we're gonna be looking at
in more detail what what that really
means in terms of the physics and things
like that well I mean it's it's looking
more and more like many earthquakes have
multiple fault ruptures and years ago
that wasn't necessarily assumed to be
the case so why that might be is
something for EE need to understand
better
the sensation could go in like opposite
directions sure it's it's just important
when you know for hazard purposes and
things like that that you consider all
different types of scenarios and so when
multiple faults are involved it becomes
a lot more complicated and that's
something we need to look at more yeah
actually that's one of the questions we
need to look at so did one fault go and
then the other was it separated by two
seconds or ten seconds to some extent
it's a matter of semantics do you call
it we call it one earthquake because it
happened close enough together and then
we talk about sub events but that's one
of the details that we really need to
dive into the into the data to look at
one point here is a magnitude six in a
house don't happen every day in
California and earthquakes that break
the surface don't happen every day so
there's a lot of questions about surface
breaks and you know there were their
relationship to what's going on at depth
so one of the key scientific questions
and priorities is to get people in the
field which is what they're doing to to
really record what happens because those
features can be very ephemeral
after six point four and not just a
smaller view by looking at the long-term
bathroom brains in that area going back
you know potentially decades essentially
I can jump in again when we say an
aftershock sequence is over when the
rate of earthquakes in an area goes back
to what the background is that doesn't
really mean the sequence is over it
means we can't detect them anymore
because the rate isn't different from
what it used to be before the major
sure there's always the possibility that
an earthquake can trigger a larger one
and so statistically speaking when we
look at lots of different sequences over
the years we can estimate you know how
likely it might be that I give an
earthquake can trigger a larger one so
we found that as time goes on after a
large event that likelihood decreases so
we estimate something like a 6% chance
as of now that there could be a larger
event that occurs it could be a larger
event 6 plus I didn't hit so the so just
to clarify there's we estimate that
there's about a 6 percent chance of a
magnitude 6 or larger earthquake
happening and but how large it would be
would determine whether it's an
aftershock or not ultimately be a main
chocolate so what was the timeframe on
that that's just going forward that's as
of right now is it six percent yeah and
that's in the general region correct yes
Ridgecrest
that's right virus how about its effect
on say the big one that we talked about
the San Andreas probably not it's pretty
far away from the center and rejected
for something that far away probably not
yesterday's quake and the aftershocks
moving forward
six
did you know yeah I think the odds that
this earthquake is going to influence
significantly faults away from the
immediate area are very very low they're
not zero but we don't even try to do a
forecast because the odds are so low it
is well away from the the San Andreas
for example so we still we always have
the background rate of probabilities of
earthquakes on every fault in the state
and those don't change we just
superimpose the aftershock likelihood
locally so for most parts of California
we're at we where we were before
yesterday before this has happened
my grandparents moved to China lake in
1946 so I can address this one so that
the base was started after World War two
so that's where everything there is new
there aren't really any high-rise
structures there are department store
type buildings there are a few
multi-story two three-story buildings on
the base but again those would have been
built after World War two with in
Ridgecrest it's mostly single-family
homes it's mostly wood frame and they
all would have been built at least to
the building codes as they existed in
1933 which is after that the Long Beach
earthquake taught us about the peril of
unreinforced masonry the newer homes
would be and so the building codes have
gotten better in time and the
earthquakes have revealed
vulnerabilities and so that the codes
have been strengthened but anyhow that's
sold in California with a mortgage has
to be bolted to the foundation for
example so they may all the houses are
not quite at the level of post
Northridge codes but they're not they're
not bad
I think Isabella people were concerned
about the dam are there any structures
that if there were no six class or
greater Creek than the one we had
yesterday might be an area for yeah I
haven't heard about anything and any
concerns for dams there were some Rock
Falls there was some damage on the base
apparently including to their Tower I
don't have a lot of details on that or
the Rock Falls again a lot of the the
strongest shaking would have been along
that L that you see and overwhelmingly
that is in a remote part of the base
which was very fortunate if there had
been I'm pretty sure we would have heard
about it tomorrow
if nothing has happened by then then the
risk goes down and we'd have to
recalculate what that would be at that
time
so the photos that I've seen the offsets
are on the order of 10 centimeters or a
couple of inches but the the most
dramatic surface rupture is almost
certainly on the base so that had there
are that has been there has been a
preliminary reconnaissance and we expect
to have that information very soon but
not right now
yes because the base is post-world War
two
most of this it's available online in
the USGS aftershock forecast is also
online and it will be updated at this
point I believe sometime today and then
going forward
probably daily for a while